the love is blind reunion is out now you
guys broke up with the altar but how
long were you broke it up for um so
after the wedding I felt like we weren't
done I reached out to him
couple hours afterwards oh yeah because
I'm direct and he also said things you
know I do want to still be with you I
still want to explore relationship with
you well here's my question do me why
didn't you tell her beforehand why'd you
wait until the wedding or is that part
of the deal engagements were all her own
completely unscripted the whole show was
right but once you got engaged you had
to make it an altar okay right why
didn't you give her some kind of signal
or something ahead of time because I
didn't know until the moment of what has
been the key to a successful marriage
for the two of you now that you've been
married for almost a year
yeah doing the same things that really
made our relationship work in the
beginning and that's being vulnerable
mm-hmm
not being afraid to talk about things
now Lauren you spoke at the reunion that
you actually dated Damian while you were
in the pods I've been every day you'd
have a date with him leading up to the
yeah and Marky's yeah yeah I was dating
the mom you were living your best life
guys I mean Damian and I we would just
laugh all the time
make jokes and really like we would use
the time outside of that laughing and
joking talking about the people that we
were really into I would talk to him
about Kim asked for advice he would talk
to me about G and same thing so it
became like a brother-sister friendship
type of thing
me and Lauren hit it off on day one we
were we could be quirky with each other
she's like Damian I am a black woman
yeah I guess and I'm proud of it now I
want to be taken out and showing off she
goes but I'm also nerd
this here is called the newlyweds our
blind game are you ready to play who is
hurt celebrity John Dean what is
Damien's favorite movie what is his
biggest pet peeve that you do dishes and
wash shirt wrong the way she loves it
how many kids does she want somebody got
some work to do right change that okay
yeah well yeah definitely one boy and
one girl and then one for fun how many
kids does she want to boy-girl - I love
it
[Music]